welcome back everybody we're bringing
you the latest out of Broward County
Florida where week three is underway in
the murder trial of rising rap artist
xxxtentacion 20 year old Jose onfroy was
gunned down during a robbery while
leaving a motorcycle dealership
prosecutors say defendants Michael
Boatwright and Trayvon Newsom carried
out the attack while a third
co-defendant Diedrich Williams is
accused of driving the SUV used to
facilitate the crime and last but not
least a fourth co-defendant Robert Allen
pleaded guilty to murder and robbery
charges testifying against his alleged
accomplices over the span of five days
he's set to be sentenced on Thursday
while behind the scenes Williams defense
team and attorney for big name artist
Drake have been battling over the singer
giving a deposition Drake had an ongoing
feud with onfroy at the time of his
death and the defense wanted to explore
a possible conspiracy a judge denied the
defendant's original request for a
deposition over a faulty subpoena after
fixing the subpoenaed second attempt at
serving Drake when app absolutely
Haywire with his armed security
literally kicking the documents down
Drake's driveway Williams defense filed
a motion asking for an expedited
deposition and Drake's team filed a
motion to strike it going as far as to
ask for sanctions to be imposed now it's
unclear if Drake's deposition scheduled
for Friday is going to actually happen
or not and we're going to provide more
updates as we learn more but speaking of
Dietrich Williams the jury saw videos of
him on the day of the murder through a
detective's testimony on Tuesday
those are two individuals want to wish
you have identified for your
investigation of teacher Williams
walking out separately yes the first
video that we're going to discuss can
you tell the ladies and gentlemen the
jury the date and time that you
perceived it to have been recorded that
was uh the date of the homicide at uh 5
29 pm
[Music]
detective in that particular video what
do we see
uh Mr Williams
Fanning out multiple hundred dollar
bills and what is he wearing in that
video uh
the gray white tank top
okay so Brian what happens if the
defense the prosecution they go through
all the witnesses before the judge can
get Drake to be deposed is it even worth
it at the end
I think at the end of the day Jesse this
might not happen I think Drake has a
good plan here kind of kicking the can
down the road because I don't see a
judge saying don't worry we'll hold off
on any kind of deliberation until we do
this deposition I think the defense at
best has one dance at this and if they
can't make it work then maybe the stall
tactic from Drake will push it down to
the point that we'll never see a
deposition I honestly don't think that
they want Drake there though I think
they want to make as much noise as
possible to say hey look there's a
reason why he didn't show up there's a
reason why he's not wanting to testify
and then they can make an argument to an
empty chair rather than Drake Well the
evidence isn't good against the defense
I mean Terry at least two witnesses
testify that Diedrich Williams admitted
to being at the shooting how damaging is
that testimony when you compare with the
new video especially since his attorney
is the one trying to depose Drake listen
I don't know what's going to happen with
Drake but Dedrick Williams is in trouble
first of all you saw him in that video
at the dealership you saw him flashing
the money he was wearing the exact same
clothing and on top of all of that his
ex-girlfriend came in to testify and she
said he told her he was there and then
he had another friend who came in and
she testified that she helped them lease
the car that went to the dealership so
he's definitely got some really hard
issues I think his attorney is fighting
very hard because as the driver of that
car he's in trouble yeah I'm not
surprised they're trying to find a
defense anywhere they can make it not
sure it's going to work but uh yeah
that's not good when we come back we're
going to return to Broward County
Florida where a new law could change a
dog's favorite pastime for good we'll
look at one senator's push to keep
animals safer that's next
[Music]
thank you
we're back in Broward County Florida to
finish out Today's Show because a newly
proposed bill could change the role of
puppy passengers forever that's right
the bill introduced by a Florida state
senator would make it illegal for dogs
to stick their heads out of a window or
sit in the driver's lap while a car is
moving the bill would also make it
illegal to have a dog transported in a
trunk or enclosed cargo or on the
running board Fender hood or roof of a
vehicle to make sure dog stays safer the
bill would require them to be secured in
a crate restrained by a seat belt or
under a passenger's direct supervision
supporters argue that dogs in a driver's
lap can be a distraction and unsecured
dogs can become projectiles in a crash
rule Breakers could face a potential
moving violation but it would encount
toward a Criminal Traffic Violation if
the bill passes Florida would be the
eighth state to enact the law punishing
owners with unrestrained dogs and
vehicles the Animal Welfare Bill also
includes bans on declawing cats and
animal Tech testing for Cosmetics so
Terry you think the law goes a little
too far I mean should there be limits
here I think there should be limits I
think it goes a little bit too far look
I was kind of surprised when I did some
research that there aren't that many
states that have restraining
requirements for dogs you would think
they would and if they did they could
stick their head out the window because
it's really cute when they do that but I
think that part of the law that's trying
to propose does make sense you don't
want any sort of animal in the front
seat that's got to be distracting or in
some sort of loose back seat you know
because obviously if there's an accident
that could be very very bad you also
don't want dogs kept in a hot car I
think that's something that should been
part of the law as well because
obviously that's cruelty to animals so I
definitely think that it's responsible
to do this I'm glad Florida's doing it
but I don't think they should say that
the dog can't put their head out of that
window by the way in that footage was
the dog driving the car does anyone not
want to address that happening anytime
soon
well Brian you're a dog owner what do
you think about this maybe it's
different for me because all the dogs
are looking at are like little five ten
pound puppies I've got a 70 pound
Doberman I'm not driving with this dog
in my lap no secure your dog this is the
way I look at it you look at dogs either
one or two ways either you have a breed
specific dog where you use that dog for
hunting defense protection whatever it
may be or it's a family member would you
put a small child in your lap unsecured
while driving no would you let a child
hang its head outside the window while
driving no so in any way that you look
at your four-legged animal uh tool a
part of your family why does it make
sense that you want to do this I think
it should be a lot I love the fact that
there's no criminal repercussions give
them a ticket you love your dog enough
to bring them in with you while you're
driving make sure they get there safe I
think it makes sense no fresh air for
your dogs Brian not letting them be free
I totally get it it's fine it's fine no
it is it's true it's it's good it keeps
them safe we can it's all good Brian
Terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on the
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice
[Music]
foreign